[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم في اليوم الخامس من عيد
العرش اليهودي نحو 1500 مستوطن يقتحمون
باحات المسجد الاقصى تحت حمايه شرطه
الاحتلال وحبس تحذر من ان الانتهاكات
الاسرائيليه قد تؤدي الى اندلاع حرب دينيه
في حين رفضت السلطه الاسرائيليه طلبا
تقدمت به الكنائس في القدس وحيفا لتامين
الحمايه لها في وقت يواصل فيه متطرفون
يهود البسق على المقدسات
المسيحيه بعد الغاء الاتفاقيات الامنيه
والدفاعيه مع باريس رئيس الحكومه المعين
من المجلس العسكري في النيجر يتهم فرنسا
بالتخطيط لاغتيال مسؤولين كبار لزعزع
الاستقرار في بلاده في في حين قال وزير
الداخليه للجزيره ان باريس تدعم الارهاب
وتحرم النيجر من استغلال مواردها مشيرا
الى ان حكومه ماكرون لم تتواصل مع نيامي
حتى اللحظه لسحب قواتها من
النيجر للمره الاولى في التاريخ الامريكي
مجلس النواب يعزل رئيسه كيفل مكارتي
باغلبيه اصوات النواب الحاضرين والنائب
الجمهوري مات جيتس الذي اقترح عزل مكارتي
يقول انه تسبب في شلل مجلس النواب بينما
اعلن مكارتي انه لن يترشح مره اخرى وكشف
عن انقسام حقيقي في
المجلس خمسه احزاب يمينيه معارضه في
الدنمارك تطالب نوابها في البرلمان برفض
قانون قدمته الحكومه يقضي بتجريم ازدراء
الرموز الدينيه بما في ذلك الاعتداء على
المصحف الشريف في اعقاب حرق اليميني
المتطرف راسموس بالودان نسخا منه في خطوه
تهدد الحصول على الحد الاقصى لعدد الاصوات
اللازمه لاقراره الى
اللقاء